this job is eating me alive I can't
breathe anymore spent all these years
trying to be the good guy the man in the
white hat
I'm not becoming like them I am that hey
what are you doing weirdo I'm doing the
best speech from Donnie Brasco actually
ten of me you're doing the best speech
from Donnie Brasco what's up get it
together man okay so the story's hit
about two hours ago they took mostly
tablets laptops and cameras sorry I'd
like a list of all your employees
whoever had access to the store I'd also
like to apologize for my partner his
parents didn't give him enough attention
hey sorry I'm late the coffee guy was
assaulting your head what is going on up
there it's a bad boy answer that
question do you currently have a knife
on you yes several and I love it it
really is hair it's bad Rosa you look
like Edna from The Incredibles I'm sorry
don't stab me my girlfriend Jocelyn's
been practicing a bunch of different
hairstyles on me she's in cosmetology
school is she that's it honestly I don't
know well let's get into this murder I'm
hoping it's a dope one all right listen
up everybody better contact captain Holt
let him know we got a tenth I situation
speak of Ty's where's yours me more
fantastic captain hey welcome to the
murder what are you doing here I'd like
to know what my detectives are up to I
don't get about you next let's get
statements from the neighbors ah hello
captain quick update another one of the
Fulton Street four was murdered here
this morning huh I'm surprised you're
not celebrating inappropriately this is
a crime scene and I'm a professional you
did it before I showed up yeah that is
exactly correct so two of these guys
murdered in the past two days it has to
be tied to the missing money admit I was
right circumstances do suggest a
connection admit it with more gusto you
were right
yes do you get a boil oh the camera was
in selfie mode but I looked super proud
of you hacking unfortunately because
this case has turned out to be important
that she's gone madeline wuntch has her
hindquarters pointed right at it she
wants to see us in our office no doubt
to give the case to major crimes
no no we can't let that happen sir we
have to do something fine I'll seduce
her I'll just put on my bike shorts and
give her a glimpse of the Quad Cities no
no that's not what I meant
I meant we have to fight her we're not
gonna fight her she's the devil and you
don't dance with the devil because you
get burned
also because in Madeline's case she has
no rhythm and her hands are like little
rat claws if she wants the case it's
hers
for the record you're turning this
murder scene into a real bummer scape
tell me you got that zingers the care
wasn't selfie one again but that was
really laughing all right okay if you
love that guy Charles sorry hey Jake you
know what it's time for I sure do
Jake and Rosa's first impressions
cast-off pattern on the far wall
suggests upward knife slices Jake wounds
on the Vics back means you didn't see
the killer coming Rosa laptop wallet
keys all in plain sight no sign of
forced entry doesn't connote a robbery
Jake but it does connote that our killer
was waiting for Adams in the apartment
did I just use the word cano correctly
he did great will you text that to Amy I
don't want to say what using good
vocabulary gets me okay
sexual intercourse crow said we're
adults Rock Paper Scissors for us to
talk to the Vics mom deal it's a game of
chance how do you always win
you always pick paper that is not true
here go again one more time
all right one more time one more time
one more time one more time all right
one more time one more time guys for
first psychology is a bus looks like the
perp knew he was after all he took was a
shipment of thousand-dollar
limited-edition Weezie's designed by
little Wayne
oh it's well I like Lily him no lily and
Wayne okay okay captain I hope you
whirring you're evaluating pants because
I'm about to put on a crime solving
clinic I am wearing my evaluating pants
but because I was just wait what are
evaluating pants they have a deep out of
pocket for my notepad and they don't
crease which is a must give it how much
I squat during an evaluation okay well
there were no witnesses to the crime
which is weird since there was a long
line of sneaker heads right outside the
window and you're actually squad just
ignore me unless you can't it's not a
problem I love ignoring you don't write
that down but continuing with the case
there were no signs of forced entry no
fingerprints and
DNA evidence okay I can't ignore you
what are you writing down there probably
at you're crushing it Jake because you
are crushing it are you trying to squat
a peak of course I'm proud has quite a
peak but I also might be solving the
case Charles come take a look at this
there's a security camera across the
street we didn't see before I have a
feeling our answers are in that footage
squat 502 Park yeah closer still do fire
closer here we go worth it
all right here's how it went down 9:45 a
man screams 90 seconds later wife goes
down to the doorman says a guy murdered
her husband and then ran off
we know she's lying we just got to find
the corkscrew to make our case airtight
I say we roleplay see if something
sparks darling thank you for a lovely
dinner perhaps we should have one more
drink before bed don't you darling me
you philanderer you're the husband the
husband had the affair I'm always the
victim I don't want to be the victim
okay Charles is the door no I'll be the
victim don't meet me door again great
okay so wife goes into the drawer gets
the corkscrew stab stab stab what did
she do with the corkscrew she dumps in
the hallway trash chute on the way to
the doorman well we checked the trash
like ten times we would have seen a
bloody corkscrew
all right Hitchcock you're up the body
the corkscrew still in the body now
you're terrible at this go sit down
you're up Diaz yeah then I toss the
corkscrew out the window and it lands on
a passing car security cam showed no one
driving by at that time and nothing on
the street okay I want in but I only
want to stab you fine
Charles door right okay sweetheart
time today seems a little harsh but if
it was a magnetic corkscrew
if the corkscrew was on a magnet it's
stuck halfway down the inside of the
trash chute I figured it out first Wow
what's happening
you have a ten pound flashlight in your
purse but not a hairdryer oh I can't see
far enough down someone's gonna have to
go down in there
someone with narrow shoulders no I have
broad shoulders have narrow hips with
broad shoulders see anything
freaks hands in there hey everyone I'm
here Jake Peralta the negotiator
oh so you're Jake Peralta the negotiator
yes who are you
Dennis call ESU this was my crime scene
before you bozos got here it's me -
Dennis I've spent 10 years as a
negotiator and you just took my first
hostage situation all I've done up till
now is talk jumpers off a rooftops but
that must be satisfying in its own way
right
yeah really satisfying saving a crazy
person's life whatever here's a little
advice I don't like you to not so much
advice as it is a hurtful statement
based on limited interaction he wants to
talk to you get the hell in there who
says negotiator on it
this is jake peralta I am unarmed and
I'm approaching the building
he wanted to talk to me keep those handy
there no boy if I'm like you just don't
care what I'm just messing with you
pirata
put your hands down give me a hug baby
Jodie first case tasty little beauties
just what the doctor ordered not
actually she recommended another week of
bed rest I was like whatever Dorcas
check it out second under police tape I
miss this what do we got back windows
broken two sets of sneaker prints alarm
went off at 11:43 and security arrived
at 11:46 perps are already gone okay I'm
thinking classic us I'm thinking old
times I'm thinking okay I'm Jacques
Guillaume and you are unreal no we are
kept burgers on vacation from France
I love it although inria went to an
elite international school so he does
not speak with an accent oh nice way to
flesh out the characters thank you okay
so I break the back window make my way
over the jewelry case meanwhile you're
standing lookout oui oui
in the front door smoking a cigarette
Chuck it ash okay so I am smoking
Betty then Oh Jacques roses own
cigarettes a habit he picked up from a
prostitute Marseilles but that is not
all he picked up why do I your
characters get STDs mr. living mine all
right so I go to the first case smash
steal a bunch of watches move over to
the second case smash bracelets but then
we hear a sound and I go leave sometimes
this won't DC and I know what that means
because I'm French but ask you to repeat
it in English just to be sure
boolie sir here yes we gotta get out of
here so we turn to leave you flick your
cigarette using the cane he's in the
cane this is awesome
voila see what I thought on we didn't
have an accent it comes out when he gets
excited great news everyone
we just got our first lead on our first
case on my first night back proving once
and for all
that absolutely nothing has changed
you
you